[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña a sonia ariza investigadora del
consorcio latinoamericano contra el
aborto inseguro
muchas gracias por esta comunicación
señora ariza como se ha venido regulando
el aborto en los ordenamientos jurídicos
de las naciones latinoamericanas podemos
hablar sobre un movimiento consolidado
hacia la legalización del aborto de
nuestra región
y yo creo que tal buenos días primero
que todo muchas gracias por la
invitación si la verdad que podemos
hablar de un de un movimiento que se
está presentando en toda la región que
el movimiento feminista en llamar la ola
verde una ola que ha alcanzado ya todos
los países de la región con mayor o
menor impacto pero que se mueve
definitivamente hacia la regulación es
mucho más en protectoras y garantistas
del derecho a la interrupción legal del
embarazo cuáles son los riesgos en
materia de salud si el aborto se sigue
practicando de forma clandestina señor
ariza disminuye el número de abortos
clandestinos con la legalización
sin definitivamente la las regulaciones
que criminalizan esta práctica de salud
reproductiva son las que empujan a las
mujeres y las que mantienen un circuito
clandestino que muchas veces es inseguro
y que genera unas altas tasas de
morbilidad y mortalidad materna
especialmente en algunas franjas etarias
tenemos sobre todo muertes maternas
evitables a partir de las consecuencias
que trae el aborto inseguro por lo tanto
si la práctica es legal y todas las
mujeres y otras personas con capacidad
de gestar pueden acercarse al sistema de
salud a los circuitos formales de
atención y seguramente van a obtener una
gran cantidad de abortos seguros con los
cuales vamos a disminuir estas
consecuencias de las que mencionabas
hace un momento que países de la región
latinoamericana están a la vanguardia en
materia de normatividad señor ariza
bueno sin duda méxico y uruguay son los
países que en este momento están
liderando las regulaciones y garantistas
en materia de aborto y también no
solamente esto sino también las
estadísticas sanitarias positivas en
este sentido uruguay lleva ya desde la
legalización del aborto voluntario de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta la semana 12 y un récord de
mortalidad materna cero por causa de
aborto es decir no existe desde ese
desde el momento de la legalización y
muertes de mujeres o de personas
gestantes cansadas por abortos inseguros
en méxico algunos de los estados no
todos la regulación de mexico hacer una
regulación federal tiene mucha variación
interna pero la ciudad de mexico y
algunas otras jurisdicciones han
avanzado hacia la legalización del
aborto voluntario y hasta la semana 12 y
con los 12 o 14 en lo cual ha disminuido
por supuesto la mortalidad materna la
morbilidad la morbilidad son las
consecuencias que se generan en la salud
de las personas que acuden o recurren a
abortos inseguros señor ariza nos
identifica legalizar la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo no es igual a
ordenar a todas las mujeres que lo hagan
en ese sentido se puede hablar de un
deber de los estados en términos de
salud pública de garantizar en sus
legislaciones que la mujer desee adoptar
un aborto que quiera hacerlo lo puede
hacer
claro por supuesto aquí me parece que es
importante hacer una distinción entre
varios conceptos primero el más
importante que es el bueno no el más
importante pero por lo menos el primer
paso que todos los estados deberían dar
y es la descriminalización la
despenalización qué quiere decir que el
derecho penal no sancione a aquellas
mujeres que recurren a una interrupción
del embarazo y esto porque el derecho
penal ha mostrado con absoluta claridad
ser ineficaz para evitar los abortos y
para mejorar la salud de las mujeres
entonces lo más importante el primer
paso es descriminalizar el aborto y
después viene la legalización la
legalización es como bien decías hace un
momento la obligación de los estados de
garantizar como práctica sanitaria que
es el acceso a la interrupción del
embarazo de forma segura
y usando la mejor tecnología disponible
entonces en ese sentido es importante
distinguir estos dos conceptos de la
obligación nunca se ha hablado y nunca
se hablará ni de obligación de acudir a
la interrupción de un embarazo bajo
ningún punto de vista y por ninguna
causa
y tan feo se habla de la recomendación
de la interrupción esta es una decisión
de las mujeres que es libre y bolivia
muchas gracias son a ariza ella es
investigadora del consorcio
latinoamericano contra el aborto
inseguro por sus palabras la
comunicación y ustedes por su compañía
siguen france 24
[Música]